I know the Koch brothers I saw you
putting this in the Facebook group that
you were your sort of summarizing what
you had learned what is the TLDR so all
I know is Koch brothers super rich old
white guys that I think support like you
know the Conservative Party so what do I
know besides oh hey I'm looking at a
email but I just got from milk bar they
have a peanut-butter-and-jelly birthday
cake my birthday's in a few days if
anyone has anyone thinking alright if
someone's thinking about you what should
they do just buy me that cake what is
milk bar is this a brand of cake yeah
Chang
David Chang he he started the like
Momofuku bars and they decide to open up
a dessert area and now that's spun off
to its own thing called milk bar and
they make trendy cakes I ordered one the
other day it's pretty good how long does
it take for it to get to you a week
oh man see that's the problem not I'm
never a thoughtful a week in advance I'm
like day of I'm like I'm gonna do
something but I need something that can
get done that day it looks delicious
Boston yeah you're in Austin okay I've
been in Austin for three weeks now I
want to come home on Saturday Austin is
lovely it is a great place Sean is like
is everyone in San Francisco gonna leave
no everyone services not gonna leave I'm
little definitely some people are
leaving I'm looking at so I have a place
in San Francisco I pay like five grand a
month or something four to five grand a
month and I am live it's like a thousand
or a 100 square feet with the garage I'm
live
in a place that's probably $3,000 a
month and it's like a 2,000 square foot
house with the backyard and like
furnished what am i doing
yeah but the thing is you can go even
further with that because like when I
grew up I lived in a whole bunch of
different countries I lived in Indonesia
I lived in China and there it's like you
know go to Indonesia you'll live like a
king you can go live in Bali on the
beach with a cook and a driver for the
same amount you're paying in Austin
right so this kind of this arbitrage of
like cost of living it really never ends
so be careful
yeah I'm just it's making me question my
life I look on Zillow all the time at
for buying a home in San Francisco and
the prices are dropping like crazy it
says the 130,000 tune does not cut off
of everything are you gonna have to cut
on your house hopefully not
if you're if you're the buyer listening
to this I'm not taking one penny less
than asking that's my position do you
have someone who's gonna buy it now no
no I don't know I haven't listed it yet
but soon good and so your friends do a
lot of friends leaving San Francisco I
have friends who were already in the
process of it this just kind of
accelerated it so some people just
lifestyle wise ready to go some people
when they're like well if I'm not
working from home and commuting I don't
need to be here so yeah definitely this
is accelerated people out but it also
feels like things are opening back up so
I think that you know things can change
people can feel differently as soon as
life gets a little bit back to normal
you never know what what people will
feel like so we'll see you as things
open up
I am very eager so you want to start you
want to talk about some interesting
stuff yeah you got one yeah I got one so
I know I get a get past media but I just
I love it so much okay so Jeff Bezos
Bezos Bezos Amazon guy he owns
Washington Post and a few years ago he
goes you know I'm gonna buy and I'll let
the editorial do its thing and whatever
else I'm gonna stay out of it but I kind
of want to take your guys's they built
it on technology to publish their
articles
I kind of want to take that make that
like a huge business and a lot of people
try this and never very rarely works but
what he did was or he didn't do it but
he was somehow part of it they've
created this thing called arc publishing
and it does a couple things the first
thing is companies like me pay money to
use it but it's really interesting that
you and I have talked about this idea
but what arc publishing is doing is to
go into companies like BP the oil
company that has two hundred thousand
companies and they are saying hey BP you
have you know two hundred thousand
employees we're gonna help you publish
newsletters and articles and stuff to
your to your employees which you already
are but we're gonna help you organize it
make sure it's read things like that and
they're saying that in the next year or
two they're gonna hit a hundred million
in revenue watch me which means I bet
Washington Post probably does maybe five
hundred million in revenue in total but
100 million in this enterprise SAS
revenue would be worth more than
Washington Post it is and I wanted to
get your opinion on a that's a cool idea
that you and I had been noodling with
for a while and they're just executing
on a really interesting way and B the
idea of branching out from your main
thing to doing more and yes like
something totally unrelated things in
some ways it's totally a stupid I mean
so there's an argument to be made like
this is just a stupid idea never do it
there's not even to be made that a lot
of people do it successfully so what's
your take on this so first this I've
never heard of a park so this is my
first time hearing about it just to
clarify they give other brands or other
companies the tools that Washington
posta they sort of productize their own
toolkit but is it always like the use
case you talked about like BP want has
50,000 employees wants to publish
internally or is it also external
publishing I think that they're still
trying to figure it out and I think that
they're building it for a variety of
reasons at first it was just for
publishers and then B they closed this
deal at BP and they I think to them
they're like huh maybe that's the way
that's the right
no I there's something to that because
you know when I started the podcast I
used to go to this podcast studio before
you guys built a dope studio in your
office I was going to this like kind of
rent a studio by the our place and I was
talking to the guy who did it and he was
like they had a sports radio station on
seven sports radio station and then they
were like well we know how to build the
studio we built one for them what if we
turned a few conference rooms into
broadcasting booths and we did probably
offered it to podcasters these hipsters
and SF they love this [__] and so they
didn't say by the way in San Francisco
there there are no they they're
basically the only one and truckin
inside yeah and so I went there and I
was like hey can I get 11 a.m. tomorrow
and he was like no were booked up from
11:00 to 3:00 on my [__] who else who
are the podcasters using this and he was
like oh this is Facebook they was like
Facebook he's like yeah they have an
internal podcast that they do for their
employees because Facebook has I don't
know tens of thousands employees maybe
50,000 I don't know but they have
managers who come in and record a
podcast about managing at Facebook and
it gets distributed only internally and
I was like I never heard of a internal
only podcast that a company was doing
but of course you know makes sense
people want it put out content training
you know different things like that
whether it's in text or audio form that
was my first time hearing about these
like internal publishing systems that I
had never really considered and that's
what they need to create a lot of this
stuff like hey everyone so here's how
we're addressing this situation here's
what we're gonna say here's the words
we're using yadda yadda yadda or we're
quitting this product here's why yadda
yadda yadda but here's how to use the
internal software yada yada yada it's a
great idea I think and you and I had
discuss a slight variation of this but I
want the listeners to tweet at me and
tell me and I always hid the idea when
people say like oh I can't do this it
already exists but I just want to know
does to success who is solving this
problem yeah okay we've talked about a
few variations of this so let's go over
them so this is all in the bubble of the
theme of what I'll call I mean I want to
say internal publishing because that
sounds lame as [__] but basically
intra-company stuff so I'll think of a
good name in a second but basically we
talked about QA starting All Hands
software because you know
big companies do all hands for their
whole employee base also individual
company you know divisions will do all
hands for their group and what you need
there is video streaming you need chat
or QA functionality but it needs to be
private it needs to be internal it needs
to be behind a wall that nobody else can
get to this so a lot of people already
have video streaming services out there
but that's for mass you know it's like
YouTube it's twitch it's things for to
go get a big audience but this is for a
select audience it's a little bit
different so we talked about that one we
talked about when we were we were going
over Hemingway and how it makes you a
better writer we were saying what if you
could do this for internal your emails
inside a company but also just a
MailChimp for your company so how does
somebody get the word out within a
company how do they make nicely
formatted easy to read you know company
announcements and bulletins that come
with the kind of tools that MailChimp
has like tracking opens and clicks and
that sort of thing so that's an internal
MailChimp internal podcasting what these
guys are doing is basically internal you
know Washington Post which is like a
whole bunch of different features and
functionality they have but these guys
have you know broadcasting like live
streaming
they have blogging they have are you
reading though the website yeah I'm
going through their products they have a
huge set of things busily everything you
would need to make watch Nepos so I
think that's just an interesting thing
to think about what if you took the
best-in-class products that people use
to publish and broadcast to large
audiences and you said how do companies
need this just for internal broadcasting
internal announcements
I remember my brother-in-law he owns
Jim's yeah I'm like 50 Jim's
and he was like yeah dude I just need an
easy way to mass text all my employees
on a text list the kind of numbers for
the day and any key announcements about
what we're trying to do he's like you'd
be surprised it's really hard to like
get this stuff set up and get this make
this a part of the onboarding of my
company so that yeah everybody knows
they should join that's the SMB
like this business version which it also
is a good idea and then the second thing
you talked about is you know when do you
when do you do this when do you take
your eye off your core business and how
do you expand into other lines of
businesses I think that's you know
generically a hard thing and it's a
case-by-case thing you have plenty of
examples where it worked and it becomes
a huge business unit it let's call AWS
being the best example of this where
Amazon takes its own sort of server and
compute system and services system and
makes it available to any company and
now AWS brings in you know tens of
billions of dollars a year and so that's
like the best-case scenario and then you
have a probably you know hundreds of
thousands of other examples that you
could come up with where somebody does
this it doesn't take off it becomes a
distraction etc etc and you guys have
considered this too so how do you how do
you guys think about this yeah so when
we consider everyone says the same thing
we go well Amazon did it let's just make
AWS for them and I'm like well you have
to understand that Amazon did it like
ten years into the business when they
were ten thousand employees and throwing
250 people at that problem is ain't no
thing and so at my company's like yeah
okay I could hire a person like I have
no problem a couple people like doing it
but you do need to get like your main
thing right first that said I struggle
with it because I have a TD and I want
to I want to do this [__] so it's hard I
don't know what like twitch I bet
twitches in the same boat they're big
enough and they can have these same
projects and a lot of the infrastructure
that they probably are built on I bet
they had to make a lot of it from
scratch after so I don't know I don't
know
so twitches ten years into the business
and you're right they invented
essentially the best-in-class
let's say live video streaming at scale
where you can have a hundred thousand
people all watching one channel with low
latency and it doesn't fall over and
broadcasting around the world nobody
else really had that problem so nobody
else built a solution and so you could
imagine that twitch could say hey we
could make this available to others and
that they could spin it out as its own
business unit and I think that might be
a good decision right because
you're taking an asset you've already
have that you were something that you've
refined that sort of battle tested and
brandable right like your sales pitches
hey we use this for the biggest live
streaming network you know out there but
at the same time it's a distraction and
they wouldn't have done it your one two
or three they you know could do it at
year ten because at that point your core
is stable it's not going anywhere it's
not gonna die and so you know I always
make these analogies and I don't know if
my team really likes it but I always
talk about like you know the startup is
like a baby
and like with a baby a baby just they
need to eat they need to sleep they need
to poop and nothing else matters like
you don't need to teach baby calculus
right now you don't need to you know do
all this other stuff and but as it
becomes a teenager or gets ready to go
to go off for college you know you don't
have to watch it so intently you don't
have to worry about is it gonna you know
keeping the baby alive every single day
that's the main objective of early stage
but as you get later stages you don't
have to worry about that which lets you
why don't they like that's a good
analogy why don't they like it
I think it's cuz I'm always like right
now we've got to keep the baby alive and
it's just like sort of a dark a darker
hue talking about it like I did this
with one of our companies in the idea
lab I was like we had one company that
was already mature it was already
profitable making millions of dollars
and we had this other project that was
totally unproven and so anytime you had
to decide where do I spend an hour it
always seemed like a good idea to spend
it on the thing that's making millions
in profit never to spend it on this
super speculative thing but if we did
that we would have never invested in the
new thing and so I made a decision I
said hey we can't have the baby and the
teenager in the same room because they
have totally different needs they need
different type of care and you know one
will always look feeble and weak
compared to the other but that one
that's people a week today has the most
growth potential and so we need to be
investing in that too and so let's split
these two companies up and let's spin
them out what about you do you think you
are like me where you have a TD and you
like starting stuff or are you the
opposite where you like to run it I have
a TD in the sense that I like I am
attracted to doing a new thing I'm
attracted to new strategies new ideas
but the second
your question was do you like to run it
or not run it of course in my ideal
world I don't have to run it somebody
else runs it takes the idea to fruition
and I get to own the whole thing but in
reality I found that that is much harder
to implement it doesn't mean it's
impossible much harder to implement yeah
this is an interesting discussion I was
reading about a
Copeland about the Koch brothers you
know that is I know the Koch brothers I
saw you putting this in the Facebook
group that you were you were sort of
summarizing what you had learned what is
the TLDR so all I know is Koch brothers
super rich old white guys that I think
support like you know the Conservative
Party so what do we know besides
everything that you've just said is the
stereotype about them that 99% of people
think it is about them and the reason I
wanted to read the book about them was
it was just interesting but what I
learned is they're far more rich than
that not in terms of money but they're
much richer character they kind of get
pegged now I'm not saying that they
don't do evil stuff but they get pegged
as these old white guys who control the
conservative party in reality they're
quite libertarian and they actually give
money to all types of charities I mean
they give a lot of money to gay rights
organizations because one of the
brothers is is gay they give a lot of
money to prison reform because they
don't want people to they think the
criminal justice system is screwed up
and they're very principled and it just
so happens that the Republicans
definitely do a lot of the stuff that
they want to give money to but they go
across the board there and the way that
they got started was the father started
an oil company and that oil company was
somewhat successful like it was making
thirty million dollars a year in
American sorry in today's dollar in
profit so like successful very
successful but the 31 year old brother
Charles took it over with the father
died and turned it into the largest
privately owned business in America mm
and so he took something that did 30
million dollars in profit to now
probably like 10 billion dollars a year
in profit and got out of oil what did
they do with yeah
was that they took their 30 million they
they owned owned an oil refinery and
they did a combination of things
including so the thing about oil is it
goes through this tower and oil turns
into gasoline but then but then the left
or sub turns into kerosene and the left
over stuff turns into Vaseline and the
left over stuff turns into propane and
so they just started like selling all
the leftover stuff and they took those
profits and then bought different
companies so they you know Bounty paper
towels they make those a lot of the
paper that newspapers printed on they
make that a lot of it's called what's
that gore-tex is it called gore-tex
what's like it's like a loo and lucre is
it lucre that's the material that Nike
makes shoes out of that's really strong
it's like that plastic they make they
they make that so they just make stuff
that originally started as oil but now
it's expands but it's still like making
stuff and their operations are basically
this like let's just like start a lot of
start or buy ton of stuff and it all
served with one thing and that's kind of
one of the reasons why I'm interested in
this topic I like that a lot
it was just a great description and B
that totally changes my like kind of
like expands the stereotype I had of the
coke brothers in my head you know I
never brought bothered to sort of look
under the hood and be like what is this
what how do they get rich are they
really just the sort of evil
manipulators of the conservative party
type of thing or is there more depth to
it so that's kind of a chance well I'm
not saying that well I don't think they
are evil I think that they do some
things that they're some of the things
they do a lot of people particularly
liberal people strongly disagree with
but take my who Michael Moore I don't
think they're evil I told you about my
friend my friend who I'm like this guy's
gonna be a billionaire he's like 22
years old I'm like this guy's gonna be a
billionaire someday he he interviewed
with the Koch brothers to be they're
like head of investments or something
like that and he was like pretty far
down the interview process and I was
like dude do you feel like you know a
certain type of way that it's you know
the Koch brothers or whatever it was
like
he just laughed it uses like his money
green okay money's green thank you
that's all I care about he's like I so
ruthless about the way he he looks at
these things I find it hilarious and
ultimately he didn't do it because
either a they didn't offer enough or B I
think they're based out of like Kansas
or Nebraska or something Wichita Kansas
Wichita he was like yeah I don't know if
I want to live in Wichita for X number
of years to do this so he pulled up well
if he got offered and he didn't take it
he's an idiot but I'm sure he'll figure
out his way okay that's that's pretty
interesting I like the anything else all
the Koch brothers otherwise I like that
that's sort of I would say that's the
Billy of the week then in this case yeah
I'll finish it up with I'm reading Co
Klan and so that is a book that has a
it's it's clearly trying to be negative
about them it's still a great read and
then there's sons of Wichita which is
their biography which tries to be
objective and then there's another book
called it's it's it's either called one
of them is called good prophet and then
the other one is called market based
management but good and describes the
Koch brothers management philosophy and
it's incredibly interesting nice okay I
like that yeah I just start reading a
lot more recently and it's like the best
decision I made which sounds like stupid
it's not even like worth talking about
but the reality is there's probably a
lot of people like me who like to read
go through these phases where you like
intensely read and then like don't read
anything for two years and if you're
that person like just do it go back to
the reading thing it's great I just did
it and I don't regret it at all I'm
reading this thing called the happy body
which is like really interesting it's
about the these guys who study weight
lifters they base their like you know
what what should you strive for with
Fitness and they're like well you should
strive for these like three or four
things that you know you don't want to
be a bodybuilder where you're just
strong but you're slow and you're
inflexible you don't want to be a baby
where you're super flexible but you're
weak you want to be X and they start to
outline it and there's all these little
tests and so I'm always doing them and
making my wife dude I'm like okay stand
against the wall standing up the wall
raise your hands above your head and I'm
gonna count the points of contact
against the wall okay here's how you are
in terms of you know body Makena your
alignment or your posture or whatever it
is so there's all these little tests
which is makes it a lot more fun to read
then
si this are you doing this because you
feel like you're getting old I'm doing
it because it came recommended I think
somebody somebody said this is a great
book and then the other thing is I'm I
basically believe that everything that
there's sort of common knowledge about
food and fitness is just so like
confusing and [__] and like
contradicts itself so so frequently that
I'm looking for better like source
material like not sell me a fad diet or
new you know p90x um this book reads
almost like a textbook and I find that a
lot more appealing because I don't feel
like I'm being sold to some program or
some you know diet and products and [__]
like that so alright I got two ideas for
you that are both based on zoom actually
I have a better idea let me go to the
better idea first okay so did you see
today snapchat did a like I do they're
like developer conference thing yeah so
they introduced us a few things and they
were like hey you know last time we
introduced games and games are doing
great and they were talking about games
to get more people to build mini games
on snapchat but they introduced other
things called minis and minis is
actually I think a bigger move by them
so minis are basically the mini
applications built into snapchat what
they're doing is they're copying WeChat
which is the big messaging app in China
WeChat has like a million little apps
built-in like oh you need to pay your
bills you just do it through WeChat and
how do you do that well there's this
little mini website that the you know
the utility company makes that'll just
pop up in your WeChat and you hit pay
and it's paid or you want to do this you
want to buy movie tickets together you
do it within WeChat like we don't do
that in iMessage we don't do that in
facebook Messenger but that's what all
these companies would love to bid love
to be WeChat here in the States
so snapchats taking a big stab at doing
that and they announced like so for
example one of the minis is headspace so
you can do like sort of a quick
meditation with anybody else on
one of your friends from snapchat they
did a movie ticket buying thing they did
you know so they did several of these
and she's not yet I don't know how the
socks do it but what's interesting here
is that snapchat sort of in a position
where they have to become a platform to
compete because Facebook and Instagram
have sort of just declared like we will
steal your we took your mojo already and
if you come out with some new great mojo
like guess what you know Evan Spiegel
you're the head of product at Facebook
actually whatever you come up with we
are gonna put in our apps as soon as
humanly possible so their only strategy
they have basically two core strategies
one is maybe they can create snap
glasses these like AR glasses and they
can just sort of get off the cell phone
game and get into the glasses game
before anybody else so that would be
like a what snap mini website what do
you call it
they call them snap minis and what they
are are little mini websites that can
pop up and be a little like utility
things to do inside snapchat besides
message each other now the second thing
is becoming a platform because Facebook
and Instagram don't do a great job of
letting other companies build [__] on
top of them people just trust those
companies they've built apps on top of
Facebook and messenger before and gotten
screwed and so they don't have great
ecosystems so snapchats kind of pushing
their chips into the middle of the table
and saying come build [__] on us we'll
treat you better than those guys will
and you kind of believe it you kind of
believe it because it's really their
only way to compete with Facebook and
Instagram so they kind of have to
actually honor this so anyways a quick
idea so in general I think that being
early to these platforms and these app
app ecosystems is a good thing there's
been several snap kit apps that have
been like number one and number two on
the App Store so they've gotten a [__]
ton of distribution from it what's a
snap kit app snap kit is basically the
toolset that snapchat gives you to build
to build stuff so it's like okay snap
kit will say you want to access their
bitmoji cool snap kit lets you just type
one line and you get their bitmoji
character you can do stuff with snap
kids their camera with all their lenses
I'm doing this course
and a lot a lot of things we talk about
our inflections so what our what our
inflections and and there's a variety of
styles of inflections there's technology
inflections which is like basically like
oh my god the Internet is now in
everyone's house that is an inflection
there's an opportunity there or a belief
inflection is like wow people really
don't trust the media what can we do to
help or people are afraid to be in
groups of thousands of people how can we
fix it
what we are seeing right now is a
technology inflection or a platform
inflection detection yes and this is it
this is like when so Pandora the music
company Tim told me that the company was
around for three years and it was doing
horrible and he said they heard about
the Apple Store for some reason Steve
Jobs reached out to them and said you
guys might be a good like place to put
your [__] here and once that happened he
was cool and this I don't know if it
will be but this is potentially one of
those yeah these are asymmetric bets
sure maybe most of the time these
platforms either don't work out or
there's nothing cool to build and you'll
waste you know a month of your time or
you might catch a wave early and you
might get to the top so for example the
very first episode of this whole podcast
chain is with Tsui and so he talks about
he was working at Microsoft and he
realized he wants to quit and go start a
company quits he moves back home with
his parents for like two weeks and the
fruit and the first two weeks he's kind
of bored and the day he quit basically
Facebook did their developer conference
and said hey we're making Facebook
platform anyone can build an app on
Facebook now so he goes home and he's
like all right I don't know if there's
gonna be a business I don't think so but
he's like I just need to start
programming in just to get my you know
get get the rust off and so he builds a
Facebook app that was stupid it was like
a superlatives app like which of your
friends is most likely to end up in jail
or whatever boom goes viral you know he
ends up with tens of millions of users
and that changed the trajectory of his
life where Silicon Valley starts calling
him and you know Duvall flies him out to
San Francisco and wants to invest in a
man [__] like that so he took a bet on
the sort of day the platform launched if
I'm a board developer today or I'm
somebody who's got you know the
code and you know a weekend I would be
building something on top of snap kit
the thing I would build is actually so I
think what's hard is when you want to
build something that gets the user to
leave snapchat and come to your app so
you kind of have to build something that
can actually do the whole experience
should just be on snapchat and it should
not compete with what snapchat does so
here's the idea
okay yes I call it cameo kick so
basically I think you could build the
app cameo on top of snapchat so you were
basically the cameo Kate would just say
cool I want to buy a snapchat from one
of these celebrities and I'll pay you
right here through snapchat and then I
want to send it either to myself or to
my friend on my snapchat list so
basically imagine I it's your birthday
coming up right when's your birthday
it's in a few days yeah you actually
bought me a cameo you had Gilbert
Godfried caught me a [__] right so I
did that last year but but this year I
could do it through cameo gave a little
new invention of vine so basically I
would go and snapchat I would open it up
I would see a list of influencers that
are that have snapchat which is like
every celebrity in the world I would
request a video and I pay right there
and then you would receive a snapchat
from either from me or from them in your
inbox and the whole cameo experience
could be built on top of snapchat
without having to have separate websites
separate apps all that stuff and you
compete with cameo very quickly so I
think that's a very simple idea that
could monetize on top of snap kit what
else what are other ideas that can
monetize and I think that you I'm sure a
lot of people have spotted this but you
you're the one who told me about it so
I'll tribute the genius to you I think
that's a great idea this is a good spot
buy you what else which one bet that one
just now yes besides um besides cameo
kit a cool idea
so ok so here's another one so here's an
idea well what you said about paint
paint your bills that's great like your
utilities and like roommate stuff right
yeah pay your rent I think is a easy one
because younger people who split rent
they could use snapchat or snap cash to
just do it and so that's kind of
interesting I don't know exactly how
much that's in
but that could be a problem that you
solve I think that you could if you're a
food delivery company you should
probably get on this because one of the
little fun things I've been doing
another birthday thing instead of cameos
somebody on my birthday just sent me
food via post mates because they know
where I live and so they just ordered me
food and just showed up in like door and
they just said you know like this is
from this person and I was like oh that
was great that's like a $20 gift that is
awesome and took them no effort and so
that's my new hack I just sent people
post mates just for fun as gifts and so
I think you could do something like that
but here's another one I saw a company
that's called moonshot very very fun
company idea what they did was they're
like hey all everybody's working from
home which is cool and convenient in
some ways but the one thing you really
miss is the sort of camaraderie and
interaction with your core lives and
what would tell the readers or listeners
and me what can I go to find that
because I just searched moonshot and
I'll see it searched moonshot escape
room so what moonshot is it's a virtual
escape room that happens over zoom so it
costs I think I think it's like 300
bucks to do the experience but it's
great you know that as a team-building
experience is nothing team you know
companies will easily pay for that for
their four groups of you know 10 to 12
employees to get together and do
something and so I I do escape rooms all
the time with my team I think is really
fun way to you know go out and do
something and so this is done all
through zoom they built the whole
experience digitally and I'm like oh
this is really smart because you know
escape rooms are actually pretty good
businesses in general but this takes out
the one biggest cost of escape rooms
which is like you know the rent and the
person the human being you need to like
facilitate a whole escape room doing
this on top of zoom is a really smart
idea in my opinion this is great I don't
know I don't know if that could ever be
huge but it could be good I'm looking at
it now it's what what's reason is that
the company owns it I have no idea how
did you find this this was on product um
and then it got shared because again
this was sort of remarkable people
hadn't seen something like this so
people started sharing it it went kind
of viral
yeah okay it's I mean you know so so
here's another one in the last three
months that we've been sheltered in
place
how many zoom birthdays have you
attended none have you none what oh my
god I've had to do five of these things
including my own I believe oh my god son
tonight mr. Furth what was your birthday
now my birth is back in April but but
but basically oh wait you know I didn't
give you anything I'm sorry it's all
good don't worry about it but in fact I
usually hate my birthday because I hate
you know believe it or not even though I
have a podcast I like plaster my face
everywhere and the cover art I actually
hate when the when the attention is on
me and it's like this forced fun things
I was actually happy to skip my birthday
but over this quarantine period I've
been to so many zum birthday parties
because people can't celebrate through
you know the normal means now I think
this is gonna last very long you just
have more friends than I do
yeah well you know that's what that's
what I do but I don't know I don't think
it's a last very long but if you could
find some way to do celebrations over
zoom if you could find a way to move I
have one more tea my co-workers getting
married on Saturday they're twitching
twitch streaming I don't know what do
you call the word they're streaming on
twitch the wedding oh nice yeah so I
don't know how long some of these last I
think the the cameo on top of snapchat
and I think the escape room over zoom I
think that's more here to stay i don't
think the birthday stuff will last very
long but i like the idea of building
stuff on top of zoom and a top of
snapchat
especially now that people are
celebrating occasions and looking for
ways to socialize remotely i would do uh
rent payment easy no that's the first
thing I'm focused on great idea that's a
good one you want to do one or two more
sure you got one or you want me to do it
um yeah I had one let me only no I
already I kind of like I did the Koch
family and our publishing kind of it one
it kind of fell into
each other did we talk did we do a recap
of death caught what's-his-name
liquid death we did not do a recap no
yeah what do you think about that okay
so two weeks ago ten days ago we had
this guy named Mike and he's heard
liquid death its bottled water I had a
lot of people have handy what message up
can't water message essence say they
think that the water was bad yeah yeah
and I think the idea is kind of cool
I don't I'm I liked him a lot I think
that guy's a winner I think he's a
winner too and I went into the thing
being like I think this idea is kind of
dumb we had talked about it before was
kind of dumb and I came out of it being
like maybe I'm shake this guy up to see
if I can invest in this company and the
reason why is sometimes it really just
is that simple so he's taking a mass
product like bottled water or canned
water is a mass product water is the
like you know the definition of a mass
consumption product then the second
thing is if you just did anything
different in the water space and it
latches on with any small percentage of
that population you're gonna have a
meaningful business and I think he's
doing something very different compared
to how the other brands are approaching
it and I really do think this is gonna
be a successful company especially once
I met the guy and I was like oh this
guy's a winner and he understands what
this is and what it isn't and that makes
sense to me yeah I would like to see how
he operates I would he's the type of guy
who I would be a little bit I would be a
little bit nervous
I wanted to know him more because he
seems like a guy that is a little
reckless and that could be both good and
bad and that's a good call because he
was talking about the previous company
he built the the brandy company that he
built and I think he's a great starter
and he saw the opportunity he starts it
he has a vision for the brand and what
the cult what the culture wants now in
terms of the blocking and tackling that
it takes to just operate for like
seven years straight probably not the
best in that other company he kind of he
was kind of vague about him he's like I
parted ways with those guys
it's all good terms you know I still
have my shares what basically it was
like okay thanks thanks for the
creativity bud we'll take it from here
it seemed like it was kind of that I
could totally see that happening again
with liquid death a person I admire once
wrote that being artistic is the exact
opposite of being of making money and
are basically artists and capitalists
are the opposite and I haven't decided
if I fully agree with that but I tend to
I Sam closer to agreeing with it than I
am not agreeing with it and that artists
are the opposite and that doesn't mean
they're good or bad you know I I think a
lot of art you should give a [__] about
the money it's it's great because it's
interesting I don't care if it's if it's
expensive and sometimes when people are
artistic I think okay you're cool I
don't think that you can make a peanut
like run a company that has to make and
save money right yeah I think that's
probably true that you know if you have
an extreme strength in one area you
probably don't have the extreme strength
in the exact opposite sort of skill set
area what I hope for is you have to be
just good enough to be dangerous in the
other area so like okay you're super
creative and you can you can build
brands you know do you have just enough
of the operational know-how and
discipline to execute on this like you
know Sophia Amoruso shoot when she was
on she was like too clearly a great
brand builder she did it with Nasty Gal
she did it with a girl boss Elvis called
to get a girl boss well she's a marketer
he's definitely a marketer and she and
she I think it's I think it's a little
more the marketing in the sense that it
is marketing but I guess it's like to
identify what's in the soul of the
customer and then be able to build a
product or brand that taps into that and
so I think she was doing a great job of
that I think this guy Mike is doing a
great job of that you know with Nasty
Gal she didn't manage the other side of
it and you know the train went off the
cliff and and so you know you have to
know enough for that or you hire
people that that complement it in that
way and if anybody has any wants of
reading something about this I just read
this blog post that was called pioneers
settlers and town planners or something
like that and it basically talks about
like in any given company you have three
types of people you have the pioneers
who are gonna you know they want to go
preach new land they want to be the
first ones there and live off of you
know what they can hunt they can kill
and they keep and then you have sort of
the settlers who follow in right after
and they start to set up the you know
the the very basic systems for life to
continue and they're not just looking
for the next thing like the Pioneers are
and then you have the town planners that
can organize like at large-scale systems
and so none is good and bad or cool and
not cool it's just a matter of like
knowing who you are or knowing where
you're at as a company and then making
sure you have the right type of person
leading based on what's needed if you
need innovation you need a pioneer if
you need operations you need more of a
town planner coincidentally I've read at
this article today called managers the
difference between managing and leading
and the idea was like people who are
leaders are great and chaos and they
don't really they're like very
comfortable chaos they're very
comfortable with ambiguity and that's
important and people who are managers
are all about creating something
sustainable that can operate each and
every day effectively and I'm for sure
the leader for sure not the manager and
and so I actually read something like
that today so we're similar yeah right
right on okay a couple other quick
things that are that are kind of
interesting so I want to get your
opinion on this just give me a dumb or
awesome
the websites called human IPO app these
guys are doing a very fancy branding
around an old idea so what it does is I
can go I can go do a human IPO so I'm
Sean I go public I get a stock ticker
which is like you know SHA or whatever
and I basically IPO off a share of my
time so I can option off up to 500 hours
of my time
you can book from me at a certain price
and then if people think hey you know
this Shawn guy he's on you know he's on
the way up his time is gonna be more
valuable in the future I'm gonna buy a
unit of this guy's time I can either
hold it and trade it later at a higher
price or I can I can I guess use it to
like book an hour of my time so this is
the record on the website now it's
incredibly interesting tell me what you
think of it for sure interesting for
sure innovative in a while and whoever
invented this is a nerd and I [__]
love those types of people logistically
I just don't think it makes sense
because well so I can buy Brian's time
well so if it was I'm looking at this
right now I don't understand why they
call it like it's they're really just
rebranding just like expert networks and
consulting like it's just like dude
something screwed so I think clarity FM
it's the same thing definitely cool
highly unlikely to work right that's
what I think I think this is like an art
project that's me this is I don't know
your how did you find this I saw it on
my think product hunt and I was like
yeah I've been following I think I
talked about to some of the previous
things I've been following these
personal I SEOs personal personal coins
that people are creating in the cryptic
note this is not crypto but it's the
same idea and I think it sort of has the
same pros and cons I think it's like
kind of exciting in a way to like bet on
people and I think it's kind of lame in
the way which is like what do I get I
get an hour of their time like no on
this you have like this guy I just
clicked on you have to buy a hundred
hours of its time at $250 an hour so
what does that mean turn is that way as
a 25 grand or turn 50 grand I didn't
hear exactly you said but you have to
buy a hundred hours from him at Tutor
and $50 so that's 25 or 25 grand yeah so
I but like I don't think like if I was
this guy and I just sold a hundred hours
of my time
I have a feeling that I would bail on a
lot of that yeah so one one piece is are
you actually going to fulfill the second
is so what am i doing it's actually
basically like a freelancer selling
blocks of design time or programming
time or consulting hours or whatever it
is okay that's cool maybe first really
special unique people that that works I
don't think this is that interesting
over all the ones I think are more
interesting are the ones where you
actually get a piece of their earnings
over the next X years let's never do
that a million years I know but some
people would some people would say cool
I'll take you know it's like people who
raise money for their company right
they're selling off future earnings for
capital today and some people might want
instead of doing it for your company you
might do it for yourself so I think it's
interesting I want to see somebody like
I'm gonna sign up for use case I wanna
but do you know these guys can you
introduce me can I be what are these
people that they that can I sell hundred
hours it seems I does seem interesting
I'm just just from like a like an like
an innovation perspective like it's just
so weird and interesting I would love to
I would love to try this I like it cool
okay so that was the that was the last
one I wanted to do do you have any other
stuff you wanna go over or anything else
on this list interesting I could talk
about any of this stuff yes but I don't
want to talk about it today
Oh on here you have what is happiness
and I'm I I want to learn all about that
I also want to learn about hyb which I
think I know what it is but I can't want
to save it because the happiness thing
was interesting to me in that happy book
I haven't pulled up on my Amazon I am
going to probably read that whole both
of the next two or three days but that
is interesting and I'll tell you why
it's interesting is I'm obsessed with my
posture right now because I've got one
like strong and fit over the last three
months and that's wonderful but I have
scoliosis my like my posture is horrible
and it's making me nervous because I'm
like what's the point of getting strong
if I'm like crooked and not healthy and
I've looked all over the place for like
good scoliosis workout routines I'm
and I just want like a just something
just like a posture doctor right and
it's kind of interesting like a like a
posture doctors kind of cool to me and
yeah I thought about that I went I went
for a run the other day and I was like I
think I don't know how to run
I think nobody taught me how to run and
then I started running a certain way and
then I got out of shape and I think I
just run like [__] and I know I don't
swim the right way or there's like a
better way more efficient way to swim
also and I'm like I need to I want to
clean all these up I want to clean up
running I want to clean up by by walking
you know cadence or whatever you call it
and then also my swimming but yeah I'm
similarly obsessed with these things and
you know you've been getting jacked
which I think you know props to you for
doing every time you send me one of
these videos you know Sam sends me these
videos that are like it's not nudes but
it's definitely more than what it's like
more than friends less than lovers we're
somewhere in between there and he says
we did it and you've been getting
checked and it's kind of amazing and you
know so so that's you know props to you
for actually doing it it's been a big
change I basically like just I don't I
don't know if I do a diet
I just eat me and only three green
vegetables and I just don't eat
breakfast and I move every single day I
don't know this it's been easy but it
has been awesome amazing but you know
what sucks it's just sitting in a chair
it totally [__] you up and so this is
my warm I got body doctor like I'm like
a posture doctor and like I just I want
to be more like a wild animal in this in
this book the happy body there's this
picture of this like inversion chair I
don't know if you've ever done one of
them I will have I think I've never done
one but when I saw it I was like well
here's the thing here's the thing I'm I
have to buy because I think I need to I
think I need to do this I think I'd wing
what did they see that inversion chairs
are good yeah I just hang I have a bar
and I just hang from my bar yeah but you
need to go the other way you need to you
need to hang from your legs and so
you're back decompresses that's what
they basically say it's for is to
decompress the spine
it's kind of long all right cool let's
let's get out of here but now we're just
talking [__] cool thanks for
listening share this with your friend
you need to just go on your if you have
a Facebook page or a Twitter or an
Instagram you need to just screenshot
our podcast and then just say this is
the best podcast I listen to and just
post that and you can tag me that's also
great but even if you don't tag me
definitely post it if you're not going
to post it delete your Facebook delete
your Twitter delete your Instagram
because you're not using it right that's
what we need from you go post it and if
you do it it's will call this game 50/50
do that and tag me and Shawn and you
will either get a shirtless picture of
me or Shawn or a third party oh okay
how could you resist all right excellent
let's get out of here
[Music]
you